attorney general it's great seeing you
thanks for being with us thanks for
having me Laura right now we have no
freedom of worship public worship to go
to gather we have no real freedom of
assembly
not even freedom of movement given what
some of the states are doing what can
you tell our viewers tonight about what
the Justice Department will do after
this limited period to ensure that our
civil liberties are balanced properly
against the need to protect the public
well you know generally speaking there
are there are occasions where liberties
have to be restricted during certain
emergencies such as war or in this case
potentially devastating pandemic but
they have to be balanced whatever steps
you take have to be balanced against the
civil liberties of the American people
and it cannot be used as an excuse for
broad deprivation of Liberty so as
things proceed you know we're going to
be interested in both what the federal
government is imposing and also making
sure that that's justified but also what
the states do the states are very broad
well as you know what we call police
powers they have very broad powers that
the federal government doesn't have to
regulate the lives of their citizens as
long as they don't violate the
Constitution so we'll be keeping it
careful a careful eye on that Governor
Cuomo spoke out this week very
forcefully this holy week for Christians
obviously Passover as well for Jewish
Americans about the importance of not
gathering together to celebrate and I
want you to listen now is not the time
for large religious gatherers I mean
we've we paid this price already we've
learned this lesson you do know what a
service by making this worse and
infecting more people
at what point in time do Americans feel
like they're going to be able to have
that right back and that the federal
government will stand up if local
officials continue this all-out
prohibition going forward
well you know as you know it as I
indicated in my notre-dame speech I
think religious liberty is the first
Liberty it is the foundation of our
republic and a free society depends upon
a vibrant religious life among the
people so anytime that's encroached upon
by the government I'm very very
concerned as a technical matter as you
know in in facing an emergency the
government can put whatever restrictions
the government is willing to put on
everybody else like athletic events or
concerts and so forth they can't
technically do it to religion as well as
those long as they're not singling out
religion as long as it's really
necessary
so I would hate to see restrictions on
religion continue longer than they're
strictly necessary and also I think we
when this when this 30-day period ends I
think we have to consider alternative
ways of protecting people I guess that
he's focused on a lot of the funerals
that the Hasidic Jews are having in New
York where people do gather they gather
and you know tightly together to mourn
and to pray and so that's the concern
I doubt something earlier today just how
you know these are inalienable rights it
means and there's a lot of Americans
today who are mourning those who've lost
their lives in this horrible virus who
also say the government doesn't have
this right to take this right to take
our rights away even when the experts
are saying this is a horrible time for
us elif wise and they're very worried
increasingly worried I think as time
goes on but they've been very patient as
well yeah I think they I think they have
been patient and I think we have to be
very careful to make sure this is you
know that the draconian measures that
are being adopted are fully justified
and they're not alternative ways of
protecting people and I think you
when this when this period of time
there's at the end of April expires I
think we have to allow people to adapt
more than we have and not just tell
people to go home and hide under the bed
but allow them to to use other ways
social distancing and other means to
protect themselves would they become a
target on in the future perhaps after
this April 30th date where a state
somewhere or local official who declares
no no no religious services with no
accommodation that you know there's a
lawsuit filed federal civil rights
lawsuit against that government action
whether it's by executive decree locally
or statewide or whether it's by the
federal government I mean when would
that happen it would it won't suit well
would you take action
well we've seen situations even up till
now where some jurisdictions have
imposed special burdens on religion that
they won't also applying to other kinds
of gatherings and events and we jawbone
the local governments at that point
saying they really couldn't do that that
whatever they were doing to churches
they had to do to everybody and they
changed their rules to be neutral in
that respect so we'll keep it we're
going to keep an eye on all these
actions that restrict people's Liberty
but by the same token in a situation
that is essentially akin to war time
there are you know the government can
impose certain limit it's more time we
had a Supreme Court that still was in
session we had a Congress that I don't
believe everyone out of session I mean
for any length of time and now we're at
a war time now and we have the executive
branch Congress is back home in their
district and Supreme Court is closed
what's that how is that the whole of
government approach to fighting a
pandemic when it's just the executive
branch and well the the the Congress has
taken action fairly substantive a lot of
- substantial action they certainly had
the ability to provide guidance and
restrictions on on how we responded to
this they've chosen to do what they've
done and there
certainly free to come back into session
anytime they want to make a course
course adjustment the Supreme Court has
for a period of time certainly during
this 30-day period you know stopped the
usual business I'm saying the rule of
law still applies during a pandemic but
they literally the rule of law I mean
our inalienable rights the law of the
land I mean this it's it all still
exists and we don't want to set a
precedent where every time experts
declare a crisis and it's scary
and a lot of people are gonna die that
we just lose our ability to function as
a government and the executive branch I
mean I know you're the executive branch
now but well we don't have that whole of
government real approach to safeguard
the liberties of the American people one
of the things that I think the president
has done very well here is to use the
strength of a federal system where
certain decisions should be made in
Washington perhaps but also allowing
each state to adapt to the situation
that confronts it and then make their
own choices and that's a form of
protecting Liberty the federal system is
a form of protecting protecting Liberty
to have the government closest to the
people make those decisions so I think
we do have that protection you're right
in the general sense that there is a
power for the government to take
extraordinary steps in genuine
emergencies that obviously creates a
slippery slope what do you call an
emergency and I am concerned that we not
get into the business of declaring
everything an emergency and then using
these kinds of sweeping extraordinary
steps but given where where we were back
in March I think the president made the
right decision I think the president's
made the right decisions for the right
reasons I think against the advice of
many people he closed the borders and I
think when the history of this is
written that's going to have saved a lot
of lives I think that given the given
the uncertainty that surrounded this and
that and the possibility that was so
contagious that it would swamp our
health care system
he supported the appropriate moves for a
limited period of time will you be
recommending going forward any type of
changes to protocols at our borders our
ports of entry they obviously a lot of
legal implications there health
screenings of people coming into the
country again given the deprivation of
Americans liberties due to a virus that
came getting without getting into the
details but it came from a foreign
entity namely here China absolutely and
I think you know as horrible as this is
and as tragic as it is there are a
couple of good things that could flow
from this experience and one is through
it to again once again appreciate the
importance of borders and controlling
who is coming into the country I felt
for a long time as much as people talk
about global warming that the the real
threat to human beings are microbes and
being able to control disease and and
that starts with controlling your border
so I think people will be more tuned to
more protective measures but also the
supply chain issue the idea that much of
what we need to protect the health of
the American people is in the control of
foreign governments who can interdict
and say we're not shipping stuff to the
United States when everyone else in the
world wants it during a pandemic was a
crazy crazy situation to get into
happened before this administration and
the president's trying to deal with it
this virus originated in China we still
don't have all the data we still don't
really know about patient zero in China
a lot of that data is being withheld
still from the United States and top
medical people are saying that what
about the Justice Department getting
involved more I guess obviously to the
American people in this battle against
the ongoing problem again propaganda
machine of China in the United States at
our universities and businesses hey in
the White House press room the other day
yes
the department is heavily engaged in
that in fact that one of our highest
priorities in the counterintelligence
realm counter espionage realm and in
protection of trade secrets is our
activities directed to defend against
the Chinese the Chinese are engaged in a
full-court blitzkrieg of stealing
American technology trying to influence
our political system trying to steal
secrets at our research universities and
so forth
and we are focused like on it we have
something we call the China initiative
we brought a lot of indictments but it's
something that we also have to expose by
letting the business community
understand exactly the nature of the
threat given what you know today about
the panoply of abuses internationally
against the United States who's the
bigger threat to America's election
security Russia or China
my opinion it's China and and not just
to the election process but I think
across the board there's simply no
comparison China is a very serious
threat to the United States
geopolitically economically militarily
and a threat to the integrity of our
institutions given their ability to
influence things and yet our premier
academic institutions Harvard University
our top schools across the country have
welcomed Chinese students in to learn
and to take part in research here we've
had documented abuses ongoing federal
investigation now indictments in in
Boston against our Harvard University
professor for conspiring with the
Chinese allegedly
any thoughts on those ongoing federal
grants to institutions where again this
is an all-out blitzkrieg why are we
allowing all these Chinese researchers
into the United States we have to well I
think we are trying to tighten up
on those programs and a number of the
universities are working closely with
the government to understand what the
nature of the threat is but it's not
just universities I mean universities
are part of the problem but a lot of
American business is just for short-term
profit or what they see is a short-term
profit they know over the long-run it's
not going to be long-term benefit to
their business but just for short-term
gain they are perhaps not doing what is
necessary in the long-term interests of
the United States gates the Gates
Foundation are in favor of developing
digital certificates that would certify
that individuals American citizens have
an immunity to this virus and
potentially other viruses going forward
to then facilitate travel and work and
so forth what are your thoughts from a
civil libertarian point of view about
these types of what some would say
tracking mechanisms that would be
adopted going forward to reopen our
broader economy yeah I'm very concerned
about slippery slope in terms of
continuing encroachments on personal
liberty I do think during the emergency
appropriate reasonable steps are fine
but a digital certificate to show who
has recovered or been tested recently or
when we have a vaccine who has received
it that's his answer in and read it ask
me anything they had a little forum
they'd be a little concerned about that
and the tracking of people and so forth
generally especially going going forward
over a long period of time are you
surprised at how wildly partisan a
response to this pandemic has become in
the United States I know everything's
political but this is about saving lives
and saving the broader life of America
and yet from drug-like
hydroxychloroquine that's been around
for 65 years 70 years to other measures
the Presidents taken working with
Democrat governors quite well looks like
it never seems to be good enough no I
have been surprised that in fact there's
very disappointing because I think the
president went out at the beginning of
this thing and and really was States
been like trying to bring people
together working with all the governors
keeping his patience as he as he got
these snarky gotcha questions from the
White House media pool and the stridency
of the partisan attacks on him has
gotten higher and higher and it's really
disappointing to say and the
politicization of decisions like the
hydroxyl chloroquine has been amazing to
me before the president said anything
about it there was fair and balanced
coverage of this very promising drug and
the fact that it had such a long track
record that the risks were pretty well
known and as soon as he said something
positive about it the media's been on a
jihad to discredit the drug it's quite
strange there's a lot of concern now
given the again the length of this time
the concern when you hear dr. Fauci say
well we probably can't go back to normal
life until a vaccine which would be like
12 months 18 months that if things don't
open up pretty soon over some gradual
reopening with new protocols all that
there's a concern about social unrest
you're seeing a lot of stores boarded up
in San Francisco Chicago Detroit st.
Louis you're seeing more of that small
businesses affected especially by theft
and and other criminal activity how
concerned are you about the social and
unrest and criminal activity in an
ongoing shutdown I mean I think if we
extend a full shutdown
that's a real that's a real threat and
in some of our communities but I don't
think it's limited to that I think the
president's absolutely right we cannot
keep for a long period of time our
economy shut down just on the public
health thing you know it means less
cancer cancer researchers are at home a
lot of the disease reaches researchers
who will save lives in the future that's
being held in abeyance the money that
goes into these institutions whether
philanthropic sources or government
sources is going to be reduced we will
have a weaker healthcare system if we go
into a deep depression
so just measured in lives The Cure
cannot be worse than the disease but
when you think of everything else
generations of families who have built
up businesses for generations in this
country but and recent immigrants who
have built up businesses snuffed out
small businesses that may not be able to
come back if this goes on too long so we
have to find after the 30-day period we
have to find a way of allowing
businesses to adapt to the situation and
figure out how they can best get started
that's not necessarily instantaneously
going back to the way life we're gonna
be afraid to go out for a long period of
time you're gonna be afraid to go to
restaurants not maybe it won't go to the
real but their health close if people
have to have confidence that it's
decently safe out there to move around
right and that's why they have to be
given accurate information but also we
have to make PPE
more broadly available restaurants have
to change their protocols perhaps or
other businesses can't stay in business
if it can't pack it in you know the only
way they make money paying these
jacked-up runs right that's a danger
that's a danger so I think we have to
allow people to figure out ways of
getting back to work and keep their
workers and customers safe
I'm not saying suggesting we stop social
distancing overnight there may come a
time where we have to worry less about
that's I don't know what when that will
be one question I didn't ask before
federalism states rights the president
has been very clear on that during this
health crisis are you surprised that sir
States New Jersey in particular had come
in to say that gun stores are
non-essential gun shops are
non-essential but abortion facilities
are essential given given what we're
facing well I'm not surprised I mean
that's where our politics are these days
but obviously the federal government
agreed that gun stores are essentially
and abortion facilities in Texas deemed
non-essential by the governor lieutenant
governor very strong on that that saw a
lot of legal challenges do you think it
was just upheld yeah well you do you
foresee that continuing those types of
challenges going forward against what is
essential in a crisis well I mean again
after this this period where we're we're
you know we have very strong
restrictions in place hopefully there
won't be a need for those kinds of
distinctions to be made oh you think the
people are gonna happen Evelyn
approaches I mean that the left is
clearly trying to use this to reshape
American society this is never to let a
crisis go to waste now we're doing to do
climate change policy and a massive
wealth redistribution for the
disparities in health care that's what
all the you know Democrat politicians
are now talking about going forward yeah
I'm concerned about that time how was
this changed your daily life I mean it's
changed everybody's lives we've never
lived through anything like this just
personally reflect on it I still come in
most days and we sit the conference
table very spread out when we when we
need a meeting we do more by telephone
and by a group teleconference and video
conference than we have before
and
you take your temperature as you come in
do I take my temperature
I was time tested occasionally at the
White House when I'm going in to see the
president and you know we're starting to
learn more as PPE becomes available
beyond the healthcare industry we're
wearing more PPE
will you wear a mask going out in public
if you just had to go to the grocery
today I know you don't go to the grocery
store but if you had to go to the
grocery mr. attorney actually where we
asked I I wear a mask and my security
detail wear masks when we go in every
morning we go home and frequently I'll
wear it here in the office I didn't
think you'd let me wear it on this
little smiley face mr. attorney John
thank you so much thank you appreciate
it thank you